It's like this, right? Ah, it's really time. It
's an underground pit that existed before Shibako was founded
.  Robobartha monster location scouting party 1
I don't want to be scared
.
There's a madder door, isn't it okay? The door is supposed to be black, but I'm going to
work
.  That
's why It's a sound
that stirs up the imagination, isn't it
?  I won't tell you
, both of you, please do a good location scouting.
You're going to get the most attention with fires,
so I did
n't ask.  The name recognition of the prefecture is
also rising Suddenly, it's a big stage The dining table is enough Then I originally
wanted to live a small life in the shade I didn't hate my pride
I should go to a bright place to have my work recognized on my commute
The metaphor is the exact opposite of his current behavior
.